episode three begins back in 1991 when
young Molly ventures out into the snow
to sneak into the Deever home she
doesn't seem to be affected by the cold
going out nothing but her nightgown
which suggests she may be channeling
Henry who is someplace warm inside the
Devers she puts on Henry's plat sweater
which will see him wear a bit later I
can't help but think Molly's use of the
sweater may be linked to the tot ash
state a state triggered by powerful
events or objects in the Dark Tower
which allows travel between universes
could this sweater be one such object an
object which strengthens the bond
between Molly and Henry it could also
explain the hourglass for if she wears
it too long she could lose control of
herself as she explains later on in the
episode Molly kills Henry's father by
taking out his respirator but is it
really her that's doing it could she
have lost track of herself and some
other forces at work here is it Henry's
anger taking control the snow outside
Castle Rock Church hints at a dream
sequence just like it did for Henry in
episode 1 Molly walks through the church
and is confronted by Reverend Matthew
Deaver Henry's father who asks her who
are you to overrule the will of my lord
Deaver says his body fell to earth which
could explain why his back was found
broken did he actually fall from heaven
or some other universe I'm curious as to
whether the other churchgoers are simply
figments of her imagination or if these
are people she is felt - pastor Deaver
ends the scene with a quote from
Corinthians 15:51 which explains how the
Dead will rise and live eternal hinting
at the end of days Molly wakes up and
takes another pill which helps her block
the voices from her head at the mellow
Tiger Henry sees a real-estate ad for
Molly if you look closely at the doctor
and the medical care ad it's the same
doctor who looked after the kid in
episode 1 Henry watches an ad for local
color the same show Molly set to be on
to discuss her vision for castle rocks
revitalization at Molly's new office
Molly places the finishing touches on
her diorama and we learned Jackie has
taken on the job of Molly's Executive
Assistant
Molly senses the arrival of Henry who
has plans to sell her mother's home and
put her in extended care he says he
needs an agent but Molly refuses to take
him on the voices in her head are too
much and she makes a pitiful excuse that
she's too busy in a flashback Henry
Burns of VHS
with the date November 23rd 1989 he's
also wearing the same plaid shirt Molly
took before killing father Deaver and
now remains in her basement as it burns
he expresses his hatred for his dad
implying that whatever was on that tape
was important to him in some way could
it be something he wasn't allowed to
watch that a pastor wouldn't want their
kid watching like porn since Molly says
she could feel him touch himself or
could it be video of his real family my
guess is this won't be the last time we
see this video molly invites henry over
where you can see the notepad from
episode two judging by the cassette
tapes this is the summer of 1990 a few
months prior to henry's disappearance
you can also make out a poster for the
Ramones who wrote a single for the film
Pet Sematary Molly tells Henry that she
can feel what he feels and we see this
manifested itself when Henry's father
angrily calls for him and she curls her
fist just like he does back in present
day Molly takes her last pill in an
effort to cope with the voices at
Shawshank the kid eats nothing but bread
for lunch he stares at the photo of de
Lacey the man who imprisoned him in the
water tank who also happens to be next
to a picture of warden Norton from the
Shawshank Redemption so les key tells
him to keep it cool and that Henry is
arranged for a hearing with his case
Henry meets with Zaleski who tells him
he needs more proof if he's going to get
the kid out Molly comes home to find her
place trashed Jackie comes to help but
nothing seems to be missing
she makes reference to to oxy fiends
who've been breaking into homes which
could be Derek and his crew in the
basement molly finds the flashlight from
episode 2 the plaid shirt hourglass note
pad pen and a castle rock paper someone
or something has obviously been through
them but nothing is taken jackie finds
the Henry Deaver poster but molly
brushes her off saying she has a busy
day ahead
practicing for her interview the voices
inside Molly's had intensified and she
reaches for one of her pills realizing
she's all out she goes to visit her
dealer who's all out as well he
recommends if she really needs a fix to
visit Derek by the Timberland motor core
in what appears to be a shift to October
of 1990 Molly can feel when Henry gets
burned in another jump in time Molly
wakes up to see Matthew and Henry leave
in the middle of the night this is
likely the night Henry and Matthew
disappear for good in the forest Henry's
father asks do you hear it
the
thing the kid asks Henry later on in the
episode Henry runs away from his father
and we see Molly blow cold air like an
episode to Molly searches for Derek and
an abandoned building by the motor Court
where she finds a group of mass children
playing a McCaw game of court
she is ushered away by Derek who's about
to sell her oxy but the deal goes sour
when the police arrive at the police
station Henry inquires about what was
found in DES Lacey's car among the items
a collapsible walking stick which was
seen briefly in episode one and two moon
pies perhaps a reference to Wild Bill
from The Green Mile vehicle for that
moon
Henry wants the items to be examined for
DNA but the cop refuses since it was a
suicide
Henry threatens with a court order but
the cop brushes him off saying everyone
in this town works at Shawshank I'm sure
Janus at the courthouse will take her
sweet time Henry bails Molly from jail
and she opens up about why she can't be
around him she tells him she loses track
of herself with him could this mean she
was acting out Henry's anger when she
pulled the plug from his father all
those years ago does she have some form
of The Shining which might play out
later since her new assistant just
happens to be someone named Jackie
Torrence
Henry rushes Molly to her interview
where she experiences an influx of
voices but watches it when she uses her
time to talk about the injustice of the
kid being locked up at Shawshank without
due process much to the awe of warden
Porter Molly drives Henry home and they
both say it was good to see each other
before Henry gets a call from Shawshank
warden Porter meets with Henry and
offers a three hundred thousand dollar
settlement for the kid Henry argues that
won't cut it this was a kidnapping but
Porter says they can't be held
responsible for the actions of a rogue
employee
de Lacey Henry and the kid meet face to
face the kid doesn't seem to know how to
use a phone which supports my theory
that he isn't from this time or place
remember how scared he was of the
electronic fingerprint scanner in
Episode one the kid asked if it has
begun
could he be referring to the war between
good and evil and later asks do you hear
it now just like his father asked 27
years ago now there's a theory out there
that the kid is Georgie from it because
of the line about boats and it being 27
years the difference the same amount of
time it takes for it to reappear but I'm
not quite sold on that the line about
boats that makes me think of no in the
great flood and with all this talk about
the end of days
the second coming in Corinthians not to
mention the kid being found in a water
tank I'm more inclined to think the kid
is a messenger from God that Alan
Pangborn and de Lacy have sworn to
protect if you think about it the only
bad thing the kid has done so far which
even that can't be confirmed 100% is the
killing of the skinhead the question
remains is the kid good or bad and I'm
more inclined to think he's good molly
arrives home and hears someone creeping
upstairs she takes out a knife and
investigates when she enters her room
for a brief moment you can see the
reflection of a bandaged priest likely
Mathew Deaver on the blade the episode
ends with pastor Deaver repeating the
words behold I will tell you a mystery
before quickly disappearing this episode
delve deeper into Molly strand and the
major impact her and her powers will
likely have on the town of Castle Rock
we're also getting closer to the kid
making his way out of Shawshank and more
mysteries have been added to the
ever-growing pile I hope you'll stay
tuned with me as we continue to unravel
those mysteries thank you for watching
this video if you liked it please make
sure to LIKE and subscribe I'm a small
Channel so every share like and
subscribe goes a long way for me tell
your friends who loved Castle Rock
because I think this show is gonna keep
getting better and crazier until next
episode catch you guys later